make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so Marvel 2099 is back and one part
of me is very excited about this right
like one part of me is just like just
2099 I love this future you know these
future stories and so on another part of
me is like 1997 is that you in the sense
that I'm kind of worried that like it's
gonna turn into Marvel 2099 in 1997
there's a part of me that's kind of
worried about that but the cool thing is
is we're gonna go with this and we're
gonna see what happens now here is one
of the interesting things about this
right this is uh this is an alpha shot
right this is an alpha comic those you
guys should we're new to this um they
don't really do this too much anymore
they used to do it all the time really
Molly's drew like all the time back in
the 1990s you would have like some seven
great big huge story that was gonna take
place so it would be like this one shot
which would be the Alpha story like Age
of Apocalypse for example you have age
of apocalypse alpha and then Age of
Apocalypse Omega so you have the Alpha
comic which basically intros everything
then you have the Omega comic which ends
everything uh and then it just kind of
rhapsodes wraps the whole story up
everything kind of takes place in
between this is an alpha comic in so far
is what this is designed to do is to
essentially preview everything that's to
come right to kind of give us a general
idea of the landscape but only insofar
as it gives us things to kind of look at
right so like if you guys remember
all-new all-different marvel point 1 or
points you or whatever was that one shot
that was like here's how everything's
gonna go that's basically what it is and
so what this does here is this picks up
in a place called the ravage now I don't
remember a location called the ravage
from Marvel 2099 back in the 90s I'm
aware character named ravage who is
created by it by Stan Lee and Paul Ryan
it was okay I mean it was he was an
honor I character like I wasn't really
interested in him too much uh he was one
of the first to be introduced in 1992
right and so if anybody regardless like
you basically had this girl who's kind
of stumbling around and this girl
discovers a hammer of Thor now the
reason why I say a hammer of Thor is
that what you have are basically these
various individuals who are wielding
Thor hammers and the reason why is
because what you had in Marvel 2099 is
you had what was called the Church of
Thor and the Church of Thor were like
these religious zealots basically who
believed that Thor would return one day
and so they kind of followed these
ideologies and like he would smite the
world of like corporations and so on and
so forth because in Marvel 2099 that was
a landscape where by corporate America
basically conquered everything right so
everything was divvied up and controlled
by corporations it was a pretty bleak
and
environment but the thaw rights always
came into conflict with the cops and so
it's kind of a cool thing because then
what you also have is you have basically
the Punisher from 2099 who started out
as a cop right who started out as like
one of these cops so the indication here
kind of seems to be that like at some
point one of these guys is gonna end up
facing off against each other but
regardless of the circumstance somebody
has seemingly been strung up you know
with regards or I guess with their with
their Thor hammer and that's really kind
of it right but what this is designed to
do this this little opening segment here
what is design of you it's kind of show
madness in the streets right it's
designed to show that like this
environment that we're living in this
this future is bleak and dark and and
very twisted and very screwed up but
that's the other thing to understand
here is for for Marvel 2099 this is I
wouldn't really say a hard reboot so
much is like a reworking or
reintroduction of it like are reworking
and reintroduction so there could be
things here that change right like this
one particular guy who is willing the
hammer mill near look like Thor right so
we may actually get the return of Odin's
son it may not really just be confined
to to the Church of Thor in the early
days right it may just be like instead
of having to wait for Thor 29 we just
get him right off the bat and there's
just a whole new person now who's
willing the hammer for but who's also a
dick you know we don't really know like
it's it's one of the cool things about
this which is why I really enjoy it
because it's it's as much familiar as it
is potentially different right so that's
that's what makes it kind of cool but
then you switch over to Miguel O'Hara
right now for the most part it's
spider-man 2099 doesn't really need a
kind of introduction I mean you you sort
of get it in so far as hey like you've
got Tyler stone and you've got you've
got Miguel O'Hara and you have him
basically working with alchemax and then
alchemax kind of doing their thing and
there was an attempt to recreate
spider-man with a guy named mr. Sims it
ended up turning out to be like this
just giant grotesque spider that just
sort of you know became all awry and
screwed up and then ultimately died I
mean there's these little things in
terms of the story of Miguel O'Hara but
the reality of this is 40 man 2099 has
been around for so long that really his
story's pretty much known right so
they're kind of retraining water here
honestly the reason why they probably
threw it in here was just for the sake
of simplicity just for the sake of
saying hey look if we're gonna show
Marvel 2099 you might as well show all
the major all the major players right
and spider-man
Miguel O'Hara is the biggest player from
the 2099 universe and so far as reader
popularity right so that part's pretty
straightforward but the really cool
thing that come from this is you end up
end up transitioning out to what looks
like the moon and you basically have an
individual you have the objectives two
voices kind of going back and forth it's
almost remain
of the earth X storyline and one of them
is saying like one of my scene you'll
answer the question what am I seeing and
the other one is saying you're seeing a
world is basically lost where the
superheroes have lost their way
humanity's lost its way these are kind
of going awry different scenarios like
that so on and so forth it ruins the
idea of like a Conan 2099 so we're kind
of introduced to a little bit of a
teaser for his character well then you
end up one and the two voices that are
talking here are Doctor Doom and who
wants you The Watcher now here's the
important thing to understand here and
here's here's where a user my questions
begin to come into play if you guys
remember the events of original sin who
bought you the watcher was killed by
Nick Fury and the result was that as
punishment for killing one of the
Watchers the rest of the Watchers can
find Nick Fury to the moon and he was
going to be the unseen the guy who was
gonna watch everything and basically not
be seen right nobody was gonna really
know he was there with the exception of
one or two people nobody was gonna talk
to him it was away from all those kind
of remove him from the landscape right
would've put him on the back burner and
say we can bring him back to somewhere
along the line the idea here is that a
watch of The Watcher has basically
returned now this is when things get
kind of murky is because you could look
at Marvel 2099 and say okay but this is
an alternate reality future one of many
futures that exists in Marvel Comics and
the result is that the The Watcher could
be back there and that would be true had
Marvel not done the Goblin nation
storyline from Dan Slott a lot of people
are saying that the more recent amazing
spider-man story is the one that makes
Marvel 2099 the absolute future that was
done long before that right they're just
they're probably just not aware or they
forgot during goblin nations but goblin
nation which was a story involving
Norman Osborn as a goblin king under
dance Lots run on spider-man basically
had Miguel O'Hara and an Peter Parker
team-up and then it was like Marvel 2099
is the guaranteed future right that is
going to come and pass right and
everything that takes place in this
Marvel 2099 universe is going to happen
right so it's the guaranteed future what
it means is that if this is the
guaranteed future of Marvel and whether
you choose to follow the goblin nation
storyline or you choose to go with what
happened an amazing spider-man number 34
I think it was out regardless of the
circumstance if you look at this and you
say okay this is the guaranteed future
did wordid a watch see the watcher come
from how did he come back and that may
be a question they do or do not answer I
mean obviously what you have here is you
basically have him like hooked up to a
chair and they've got something in place
of his eyes right so it may be I mean
with us with his eyes having been
removed by Nick Fury it could be done
like he was resurrected or maybe he's
hooked up to machines and it just kind
of functioning in some base level state
but being able to have like cohesive
conversations indicates it is full on
who ought to the watcher in in the form
that we remember somehow having reached
which begs the question how do we get to
this point that's when you start to sort
of talk about what's going on with
Doctor Doom in 2099 and what you end up
getting is just really cool circumstance
and this is where Marvel's changing
things from the way it originally was in
the 2009 universe and the 2099 universe
back in the 1990s what you had was this
massive war that broke out between
mutants and humans right it was the
mutant human war which had been teased
for decades right I mean had been it had
been teased for eons since Chris
Claremont took over started with project
wide-awake and then went into the mutant
Registration Act and all that kind of
stuff and it was like at some point of
war is gonna break out between humans
and mutants and it did right and the
result was that you kind of led to this
sort of almost complete and total
collapsing of society in this one what
you end up getting here is this massive
civil war between the superheroes that
basically leads to this future and this
is why things get kind of crazy right
because as cool as this is this future
really kind of seems to stem out of a
lot of what-ifs right like what if the
Civil War never ended like I mean Civil
War ended and all the superheroes are
friends which means that maybe somewhere
along the line another civil war breaks
Oh hopefully not Civil War to that story
sucked but hopefully something like
Civil War three ah that basically breaks
out and then like we end up having the
Marvel 229 universe honestly what I'm
really kind of hoping they do here
because this isn't really enough for us
to explicitly know what's going on what
I'm really hoping we get is some kind of
like a one-shot or in expose or
something like that
it basically says like here's the
chronological history as it exists now
with Marvel 2099 either we're keeping
all the original stuff or we're changing
it we're bringing in new stuff or
whatever the case happens to be but to
give us an updated kind of origin on how
this universe came into existence or at
least what led to this this particular
timeline in terms of things that took
place in the past but following this
what you end up having is a guy who is
basically escaping these these various
police forces in one of the towns and
ends up in transverse city now
transverse city was one of the original
introductions in in Marvel 2099 and this
is basically a lawless town but it's
lawless only so long as you keep moving
less you could do anything you want to
so long as you're always on the move so
long as you're traveling somewhere but
you can come and go right in transverse
city kind of occupied the space between
Detroit and Chicago or at least you know
what was Detroit and is Chicago just
this giant you know mega city more or
less and so basically you could do
whatever you want here as long as you're
constantly driving when you do like you
get stopped for a split second but if
you stop too long the cops will catch
you and they'll arrest you and take you
away and so it's kind of a crazy thing
because this guy ends up sort of just
running or at least as he's trying to
make this escape
he's caught it by one guy with with of
course you no longer hear this verse is
like hey look you know I can help you
out I mean your car's pretty damaged so
on and so forth we could take care of it
for you and when they get them to him I
get him to a mechanic of course they end
up basically saying we're gonna charge
you like 300 bucks right like we're
gonna rip you off oh pretty bad just to
fix this one little thing not only that
like once it happens they basically just
start like piecemealing his car right
they just they they just kind of start
screwing him screwing him over and then
the guy on the motorcycle basically
takes off like thanks a lot man and then
basically bails and that's that's kind
of a crazy thing here because who this
guy is we'll find out here in a second
but at that point that's when you jump
over to to the character of Herbie this
is why I say it's the nature of these
kind of alpha comics you jump really
fast from one thing to the next to kind
of give us a preview of everything
that's going on and you basically have a
couple of guys who are sitting in a bar
who were sorting it's a problem really
just kind of talking about their stories
and you know probably embellishing so on
and so forth and you have a little
Herbie now Herbie was a part of the
Fantastic Four back in the day he was
kind of created as part of the Fantastic
Four team and ultimately when he shows
up you're saying things like you know
can you help me find my mother's French
you know my mom sent me out here said
find her friends and I'm trying to find
them and so on but I'm not having any
luck and you know can you help me out
not really knowing what Herbie's
something into now of course Herbie was
going to be dismantled and taken apart
you know hurry was gonna be eliminated
but then Herbie is ultimately saved by
venture now again this is where things
get kind of interesting because
originally venture was a bounty hunter
that was tasked with basically tracking
down Miguel O'Hara and so he originally
appeared in spider-man number two
spider-man 2099 issue number two and
only showed up for about 80 issues right
he wasn't a very long really the guy
version of him back in the day wasn't a
very long was a very long standing
character instead like he was just kind
of a character that was there now of
course is a chicken this one um the idea
was is is that they they seem like
they're gonna have a bigger part like
she's gonna she's gonna have a much
bigger part than in in previous years
which is actually gonna be kind of cool
I'm curious to see what that role is
going to be I mean pairing her up with
Herbie and then having her go through
and and help her be I'm curious if it's
really gonna be more than adventure
following her or whatever the case is
but I have a very hard time believing
she's gonna be confined to like eight
appearances you know in in the 29
stories and that's gonna be hit so this
is why I say this is as much a
reshuffling and a changing up as
anything else right these are just kind
of moving away and sort of sort of
shifting around and and so on and so
forth so is as much introduction of new
stuff as it is old stuff but it's one of
the funny things because you kind of
begin to sort of wrap this up when you
get with when you end up getting
dr. doom and The Watcher who are sort of
watching it watching these things go
down and when you have the the watcher
and Doctor Doom conversing with each
other it's basically like there's other
people who were trying to impersonate
dr. doom seemingly trying to take on his
armor or whatever the case is but it's
one of these things where like dr. doom
is kind of like this world that that he
perceives is not a terrible place but
it's a great place to be in it's a world
where people are basically free of their
most base ambitions or desires they can
kind of be themselves whatever the case
is but it's a pretty screwed up scenario
what this does is it basically says all
these things that we've seen so far over
the course of this of this comic we're
gonna see continued in Conan in a Ghost
Rider Punisher Fantastic Four and
spider-man of course all these being
2099 titles and as far as I'm aware I
think these are gonna be one shots but
they may be ongoing series I want to say
out read somewhere at one point that
they were all gonna be one shots um I
should probably follow up on that so I
know what kind of stories I'm gonna be
covering but it is cool right I mean
it's a good little preview issue that's
really what this is right that's really
all of these these things were we're
just preview issues right so this is
basically let us kind of go through and
see all these different things you know
to watch for like the major 2099 event
which is probably gonna spin out into a
whole series of 2099 stories and yeah so
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become a become a member of the rod fork
there we go
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]